[Music]
hey you guys
so now i'm confused
because i don't know what they're
talking zach is up there saying i
thought wednesday was the main show
night and i was like it is but it's
tuesday it's tuesday and then but then
for a second i was like did we sleep
through a whole day and it's actually
like wednesday no it's tuesday
yeah he's tripping
yeah we've been doing the main shows
like on wednesday for a while now for a
while yeah we're doing uh actually the
show we're doing tomorrow night is going
to be all about
different uh road rage incidents
i picked like four different ones that
we can do uh that a couple of people
have requested you you all right we're
keeping you awake yeah
yeah yeah
how about that worked all day today well
yeah you put up blinds and trim your
head
but yeah so i [ __ ] repainted the
mailbox put new numbers on it
oh i didn't know you did that i didn't
see out there yeah
yeah so uh
as we promised i'm gonna tell these
people last night we watched the third
of the mummy movies tomb of the dragon
emperor from 2008.
and
it wasn't bad i liked it better than the
second one yeah i think i thought it
rivaled the first movie
i mean i think it been better
yeah it's just kind of like it's just
different it was china instead of uh
yeah
egypt i don't really understand like all
the hate it gets like in a way i can
understand um you know the second one
maybe inspiring more ire just because i
mean basically because of the shitty cgi
at the end which like there's you know i
know it was ilm and it's they didn't
have a lot of time but you know that i
can see so i can see people like getting
[ __ ] on that but the third one was
actually like a perfectly good yeah
movie i thought i thought it was like
pretty enjoyable it was as good as the
first one and i think it fixed some of
the things that i complained about in
the second one because one of the things
that kind of bothered me i liked the
second one too but one of the main
things that bothered me about the second
one was that it was too [ __ ]
convoluted there was like too much [ __ ]
going on um and you couldn't really you
know there was just like all these plot
threads and some of them didn't really
like resolve themselves
the third one
i liked they just kind of kept it simple
kind of like the first mummy movie where
it's like there's still a mummy sort of
but it's in china and it's the same kind
of deal it's you know of an ancient
warlord and he wants to like raise an
army and like bring him back from the
dead and he goes around like killing
people trying to get his powers back and
[ __ ] like that and that was it that was
just like all they didn't have all this
stuff about oh you have to get this
bracelet and this thing and the kid
getting kidnapped and all this other
kind of stuff they kind of like kept it
like a pretty simple twist
and i like that they did that and i
really like that they're that they use
like the real angle of like the terra
cotta army yeah uh you know in
which was very indiana jones you know
what i mean we're gonna do a show about
that well yeah i put it in the poll uh
for not you know not this week obviously
but the poll for next week which i post
on patreon on friday sharon d's tomb
yeah the first emperor of china it's
underneath there they don't want to open
it but they know it's
mercury deposits coming out of the soil
in the shape of a [ __ ] map of china
in there there's some kind of [ __ ]
mechanical lake with
moving around
mercury
a river of mercury and [ __ ] water
with mercury and [ __ ] with paddles and
[ __ ] yeah that's what's taking them so
long it's like they do have some of it
excavated because i've seen pictures of
it but oh they're trying to get down to
the main chamber yeah okay i mean i
stopped
i saw pictures of it a long time ago
they excavated it from in
i don't even remember when
yeah they've some but i've seen like
pictures of the inside so they have done
it but it's just they're trying to get
more of it done as far as i can
determine but they're that's it's kind
of slow though they got pictures of
inside there now
i saw pictures of the inside of it like
from back in the 70s oh that's not the
same one though
it's not the same one they won't let
they won't let them go in there last i
heard
i don't know i haven't like followed it
up but i just remember reading about it
and seeing pictures of it like in a book
that came out back in the second the big
mercury lake and everything
yeah i don't know about that i remember
the pictures but i remember seeing
pictures of the terracotta warriors yeah
yeah that's about it that's not inside
the main that's not inside the main
complex yet they thought about possibly
drilling through drilling through there
and sticking a camera in there and i
think maybe they may have
gotten part of the way or they did it
partly and saw something but
you know they're afraid that oxygen will
get in there and [ __ ] with everything
well yeah that's that's uh that's a
concern yeah but they do know that if
there's
mercury deposits coming out of the soil
in the shape of the rivers of china so
there's a map
it's almost pretty cool when you think
about running mercury for water can you
imagine how badass that probably looks
yeah i mean super poisonous yeah but you
know what i mean
probably that mercury vapor did to the
inside of that place over the years
maybe not yeah yeah you never know
depending on the conditions i guess yeah
zach says is this the one with the hot
asian dude and uh michelle yeo sexy ass
yes it is yeah it's got that's jet li
actually it's got an all-star it's got a
all-star chinese cast playing the
chinese characters in it it's good i
mean the only thing i could see that
maybe people might knock this for is
that it won it wasn't egypt
and maybe like what pandering to the
chinese government maybe
other than that i mean
i thought it was as good as the first
one
yeah i mean honestly the only thing i
didn't really i mean i i liked maria
bello
in it um playing evie
but i do kind of wish they could have
got rachel wise back again like to play
that character because it's very obvious
that i mean she's a good actress i've
seen her lots of other things but
she was you know really not the same
character
um it was slightly less
fun it still had humor in it
um but it wasn't like as
fun and i felt like brendan fraser
was like more which you know i don't
want to like call this the criticism of
the movie necessarily because even in
the movies universe
his character and his wife are like much
older and they've retired
from exploring and they're kind of
getting bored so that's that's why they
want to go on this big long adventure
again because they've kind of been stuck
you know because like the the last movie
the mummy returns that took place in
1933 1934 something like that this one
takes place in 1946 like after world war
ii
so
you know you can like forgive them for
not being and there's actually kind of a
practical reason too because i don't
know if you know this but brandon
brendan fraser
did a great deal of his own stunt work
on all of these mummy movies and by the
time this one rolled around he was
[ __ ] up
um basically he said at this on this
movie he said i was held together with
like ice and tape
uh he'd had like several back surgeries
he had like surgery on his jaw he was
just like all [ __ ] messed up and uh i
mean what a [ __ ] trooper man like he
did but he
talked about it later on that it was
just like i was in [ __ ] constant pain
like pretty much like through this whole
entire shoot um so you can see that he's
like not quite as like perky and fun as
he was but he did do like a lot of
[ __ ] stunts in this and
you know man fair play to him i kind of
feel like maybe he got a little bit
shafted because this was
um i was reading an article earlier that
maybe this ruined his career in the
sense that it tore his body up so much
that he couldn't really do a lot of like
action roles anymore just when he was
kind of like getting known for doing
that
which is kind of a shame uh he's sort of
i think he's kind of making more of a
comeback now like in sort of like
dramatic roles now he's older but
you know he probably could have gone a
lot farther had his [ __ ] body not got
so [ __ ] up like doing these movies but
you know he wanted to do his own stunts
i'm not sure i bought it too i'm just
we got dudes that last a long time in
pro football
well it depends more it depends on you
know dude should have been roided up
[ __ ] like that yeah
um zach says is jenny thinking of the
one they found with the mummified woman
in the inverted pyramid
i don't think so i'm just yeah they
found old they found an old uh chinese
queen or princess
she was in a glass coffin
uh
in formaldehyde basically uh just
pickled
floated in that [ __ ] she was [ __ ]
looking bloated and plump she was fat
when she was alive she's in her 50s
they did autopsy and she's well
preserved did her autopsy in her she was
just riddled with [ __ ] tape herbs
mmm yeah
it was still fat
so because the [ __ ] you should be losing
weight if you had a bunch of tapeworms
in you
well maybe she was like eating extra to
compensate for all kinds for all of this
stuff the tapeworms she's like i just
can't get full i don't know why
yeah uh grampar says i doubt brandon
frazier could do much stunt work these
days except cheeseburger noshing yeah
but you know like i said he was kind of
all [ __ ] up and zach said the same
thing happened with daniel craig on the
bond movies that's part of what he left
the role because it was tearing his body
all up because of all the stunts and
blah blah blah
um
so let's see let's see
yeah uh okay so
this one you know that they were
actually going to make a fourth movie
after this one and it was going to be
like aztec you know what i mean they
were gonna like go explore some aztec
[ __ ] which actually might have been kind
of cool they had everybody back
like everybody like signed on but then
they decided that [ __ ] it we're gonna
reboot it and do the whole dark universe
thing and then they did the tom cruise
movie so that was probably a mistake but
honestly
i would have watched because you could
tell in this one too
that
you know brendon fraser and maria bello
like you know the o'donnells they were
not they were still the focus of the
movie but the focus was starting to
shift toward
their son alex who like i said was a
little kid in mummy returns and now he's
like a college student and that's kind
of what happens like he's a college
student well he's supposed to be a
college student but he's
uh quit college and has gone to shanghai
to find this
tomb without telling his parents
and it turns out that evie's brother
uh bontiatus that's just what we call it
we're just calling fatiha
because that's just what we know him
from from spartacus that's a much better
role i mean he's great in this well the
funny thing i read because he mostly did
like dramatic roles obviously but it's
like
it's funny because when they asked him
to be in the first mummy he thought it
was like a mistake or something like
that because like i'm not a comedic
actor
but having said that he's got like
really good comic time like he does like
some funny [ __ ] like in some of these
movies so i don't know why he thought
that he couldn't do it wanted to throw
some money his way he's good at it yeah
but i you know i just always know him as
[ __ ] vatiatis if you guys haven't
seen [ __ ] spartacus i think he's in
the first
two he's in the first two seasons of
[ __ ] spartacus he just [ __ ] knocks
it out of the park his his character is
epic
he's like the roman version of the dude
from breaking bad i guess
i mean both him and like lucy lawless
are [ __ ] great they're like the best
[ __ ] there's i mean spartacus is cool
too but it's like they're they're
interesting because they're like really
conniving and even him and lucy lawless
and just random teenage girls having
[ __ ] full-on threesomes
and it's [ __ ] like explicit
and they're always it's soft core porn
yeah hardcore but it is soft
and they and they're devious well she
there but there's a reason
yeah that's a great series i know i love
that too yeah i mean honestly like the
first well because the first series had
batiatas and then like the second one
was a flash black was like a prequel
yeah and then they were in it too like
showing how they go how they rose to
power or whatever
but yeah so this one just much like in
kind of like i guess the last indiana
jones movie you know where they were
he's kind of like passing the torch on
to his son they did the same thing in
indiana jones and they were trying to do
the same thing here so i'm kind of
feeling like
what they were gonna do if they did a
fourth movie which they were planning on
they had the posters and everything and
they had everybody signed on to do it
all the actors but then they decided not
to do it but they were gonna take it in
that direction where they were slowly
phasing out
the parent characters and going more
into you know alex being you know the
kind of indiana jones stand-in
which
i don't know that maybe could have
worked although
i have to say the the
actor that they had playing
alex in this movie
was good but he's not super charismatic
so i don't know if he could have carried
a whole entire movie franchise
by himself
um
because when you had like the first two
mummy movies that have like brendan
fraser in the you know at the forefront
you know he's a lot more charismatic and
kind of you know likeable in the same
kind of way that you know harrison ford
as han solo was i just kind of feel like
maybe
they could have got like a little more
of a charismatic actor to play the sun
but he's fine in this
but i kind of feel like if you're going
to see a mummy movie you kind of want to
see brendan frazier fighting a mummy you
don't want to see brendan frazier's kid
fighting mommy you know what i mean
but
that said like i said i thought this was
cool i thought it was cool because it's
still technically a mummy
it's still like an ancient curse it's
still kind of a similar vibe
but
they kind of had the balls enough to
take it in a different direction so
there's like we're doing a tomb but it's
in china it's got a father-son theme
kind of like kind of like that uh
[ __ ] last crusade yeah yeah yeah
that's kind of what i was thinking
but so
so i like that they just kind of said
well we're gonna do sa similar kind of
thing but we're gonna take it a
different direction do like use
different mythology because honestly if
you brought like as much as i liked
imhotep uh you can't bring him back a
third time because like i said you know
he got pulled into the underworld at the
end of the last or the second one and
it's just kind of like probably be like
oh we're in egypt again like you know
what i mean story played out yeah and
the only thing that is kind of sucky is
that they couldn't bring like artist bae
back because that wouldn't have made any
sense i think they did ask him uh
because he was kind of like something
that a lot of people liked about the
series um and he said something like i
don't know anything about china
you know what i mean uh and it would
have been as much as i would have liked
to see him in this it would have felt
kind of like shoehorned in because his
you know he's his thing is egypt he's
supposed to be guarding that [ __ ] there
he can't be like off gallivanting around
the world he's got [ __ ] to do
so
you know so as much as i would have
liked to have seen this and seen him in
this one you know it's probably better
that he wasn't in this one so they bring
back the brother he's you know they he's
running a nightclub in shanghai which
like i said that's totally fine that
totally makes sense and that's how the
sun ends up there because he's like oh
he's staying with his uncle while he's
on the down low like digging up this
tomb
and then it so happens that there's this
whole plot
where they're trying to bring the
o'donnells the parents to shanghai
uh to get this thing to bring this uh
you know this emperor like back to life
and they're gonna find shangri-la and
all this other stuff now some people got
it's funny i was watching a review of
this earlier
and i kind of feel like most people's
first reaction when they saw
that there were yetis in this
was
are you kidding me yetis but then i'm
like why not why not because like
it was mummies and [ __ ] scorpion
monsters it's like oh nobody said boo
about that but the second there's a yeti
everybody gets all up up in arms about
it come on now the little cindy warriors
these are fantasy movies anti-warriors
and [ __ ] i mean even in the first movie
you had like you know you had all kind
of like [ __ ] you had a pharaoh guy
that could like [ __ ] make a big sand
thing with his face in it and like all
of them bring up plagues and [ __ ] like
that so everybody's gonna quibble about
some yetis [ __ ] that i actually quite
liked the yetis yeah i thought that was
cool there was one of the strangest like
[ __ ]
gun guy conversations in this one that
was a little weird
because you see it was like a father-son
thing [ __ ] arguing over the [ __ ]
guns
the old guy's carrying the traditional
stuff
like a [ __ ] peacemaker and a [ __ ]
45s and [ __ ] thompsons and then the
young kids [ __ ] got walter p
and a [ __ ]
soviet pps43 which is that was a hot
[ __ ] sub gun in in in those days
and uh
it's funny because
he's they're trying to outdo each other
like gun talk
but they can't do that in a movie for a
general [ __ ] audience because
they wouldn't understand the technical
terminology that actually
makes a difference between those guns so
they have to make up attributes
that didn't really apply to those guns
so the audience would understand that
there was a difference between a piece
like he was saying that the difference
between a walther p-38 and the [ __ ]
and the the the the
the difference between the walther p-38
and the [ __ ] uh cult 45 was um not
size size doesn't matter it's the
endurance
and but no mention of that the [ __ ]
walther
that the [ __ ] browning high power
that the other dude was carrying has
twice the so-called endurance of the
p-30 just weird [ __ ] you know i mean
that gun guys would pick up but the
general audience would wouldn't and then
they just
because they couldn't use technical
terminology
to [ __ ]
well because it does they wouldn't
understand it so well and it doesn't
need to be in there anyway it would just
be
you know it's just supposed to be like a
funny little scene like showing yeah oh
how competitive these two are you don't
need all this like nerd kind of stuff in
there because that's what it would have
been though that's what i'm saying but
i'm just it's just kind of funny they
had to make up stuff about the guns that
connor really wasn't accurate but you
know whatever like i said it's just like
a fantasy movie with yetis in it right
they just wanted to show hey these two
are like super competitive they're good
collections i just thought it was fun
and they just had to find a way to get
that a claw across in a way that is in a
way that most people would would get it
yeah and their eyes wouldn't glaze over
you know what i mean yeah i just thought
that part was funny
but yeah it well i honestly it was like
a little bit odd in there that it was
kind of like an odd little scene i mean
i do i guess that they did kind of
establish though didn't they that like
uh
that brandon frazier's character was
kind of like real into like fire power
and oh yeah well they both well they
were using guns through the whole thing
it was carried out yeah
no i mean in the in the earlier yeah he
was like cross draw [ __ ] under the
arm [ __ ] 1911's and [ __ ] you know
what i mean which you know but that
would have been a [ __ ] awesome rig
back in the back in those days
that'd be the equivalent of carrying
like a couple of desert eagles or
something but uh
yeah you know and then what was cool is
that he busted out the pps the the peop
the pps43 which is a soviet sub sub gun
it's out of step sheet metals kind of
like the predecessor to the ak-47 but it
was pistol
cartridges 30 talk ref he talked about
it [ __ ] talked what he used it for
only about [ __ ]
one minute and they never even show a
clear photograph of all you see is the
muzzle blast from it
once i said well damn why didn't they
showcase that he talked about how bad it
was why didn't they showcase it they
didn't which i thought that was a
strange
decision because they showed case to
other guns like a lewis gun and stuff
and
let let the audience see what it would
do and you know
hugo said i liked the yetis but i didn't
like when they scored touchdown
i you know what i wasn't even like i
guess i wasn't paying close enough
attention i didn't even realize that
that little gag was in there until i was
watching another someone else's review
of it and they pointed it out and i said
oh yeah i didn't even realize where one
of the yetis like picked up one of the
bad guys
and threw him like through a thing and
then he made like a like a touchdown
kind of thing and it's like like i said
i wasn't even because i'm not a big like
uh football purse so that wouldn't have
like immediately registered with me but
then if you tell me i'm like oh yeah
yeah okay i get it now but it's like
there was a bunch of stuff happening
there that people you had to pay
attention to see like the undead guys
the skeletons that came out
in the background of one scene a guy
accidentally knocked the other dude's
head off
we'll see i tried to put it back i
noticed that because i made a little
thing i was like oh sorry carl
they were doing stuff in the background
and [ __ ] [ __ ] up in the background
but that was that's consistently because
i kind of feel like there was a lot of
like little sight gags like that in the
first two
that they didn't it was just going on in
the background they didn't really call
attention to it but like i said i think
that's kind of cool that they that they
kind of did that that's why that i think
that's why that one soldier like the
because you know um michelle yeah or she
brings up the um
uh all the
dead soldiers from underneath the great
wall of china like to fight against the
terracotta army i like i said i really
liked the special effects in this one
were like much much improved i know this
was like seven years later than the
second one so it looks like they got
their [ __ ] together um and i liked the
whole idea of the emperor coming back
and being encased in terra cotta
but he's still kind of like a mummy
underneath there and i like that he was
like breaking off bits of his face and
like chucking him at dudes and stuff
like that and then it would kind of like
come back
and then so he's like walking around
kind of looking like a terracotta
soldier i thought that was like a really
cool idea
uh i will say that one special effect
that really didn't hold up
was when jet li goes into the pool like
the immortality pool or whatever like in
shangri-la and then he comes out and
there's like then three of his heads
and then the heads like turn into the
dragon
the dragon looked cool yeah but the
three
cgi heads like the faces that were going
in that looked a little bit yeah man
they should have just superimposed real
faces there over those they're whatever
happened to superimposure they used to
be able to do that but see that's what
well that's what we were saying before
it's like it's when you do cgi and you
just do like a creature
even if it looks kind of shitty it still
looks okay because it's just a creature
it's not real if you're trying to make a
face that looks like a real person like
jet li or the rock for example um then
it's much harder and you're gonna have
like some uncanny valley action going on
so
i kind of feel like they could have
i don't know they didn't really have to
use cgi for that i felt like they could
have just used like his actual face but
then like you know copied it like a
couple times and then you know drag into
the [ __ ] out of that so that was the
really the only special effect that
stood out to me as being maybe like a
little bit questionable but other than
that it looked like pretty good
and
like i said it's not i definitely liked
it better than
the second one
um if we're going outside the franchise
i liked it better than indiana jones and
the kingdom of the crystal skull oh yeah
for sure
you know what i mean they're gonna try
to make another one they're making
another one
i'm not a verse i do like the idea i
like because there's a lot of [ __ ] you
can do with that like an archaeologist
because i like archaeology [ __ ] and
if you're not trying to make it i don't
know i think if they did because
harrison ford is like old as [ __ ] now
if they did something less like an
action movie or they could still do an
action movie but he's not doing the
action but they can have other people
doing action but i kind of feel like
maybe they should lean more into like a
mystery or a horror kind of direction
well in the the one that they're making
now he goes back in time he's he's
dealing with the young indiana jones
they've cgi'd a guy in there to make him
like he wasn't [ __ ] raiders of the
lost army see but see that's just going
to be a whole like i said that's going
to be a whole like uncanny valley the
movie yeah we'll see i really i would
rather it's not out yet i would rather
watch
old harrison ford yeah like being grumpy
and like
trying to solve like an archaeological
mystery while other people jumped around
and [ __ ] yeah that's fine
no i'm just saying if they have to make
one i would rather them not they
shouldn't make it at all yeah
and and really didn't they already do
like didn't they do a series called the
young indiana jones chronicles with uh
what uh
ripper phoenix wasn't he in it i don't
know i don't care who cares no i'm just
saying i don't remember like ever seeing
it but
i thought they already did remember
phoenix was in one of the movies as the
young indiana jones i don't know if he
was in the tv series
yeah maybe i'm thinking of the movie
yeah he was i think he was in the movie
wait was that crystal skull was he in
the crystal skull movie no
it was um
or that or was it the one with sean
connery it was with shawna connery oh
right that's right
i can't remember yeah it's it's
what the [ __ ] happened to the crystal
skull one
it's around
it's around he said what happened to it
right no i said what happened in it
that's when they uh i remember
was [ __ ] that's who okay that's what
i was thinking it was shia labeouf
that's right
that douche
he just said i don't know if he's a
douche
is he okay he just i mean he just seems
like just from looking at his face like
i said i don't know a lot about like
celebrities and stuff like that
i don't usually know this guy i think he
walks around gets in trouble at
mcdonald's and gets thrown in jail and
[ __ ] freak out and screaming at
mcdonald's and throwing stuff he's one
of those does he have some kind of like
mental illness or did you just do it for
crack i think oh okay i'm sure that
doesn't help yeah but yeah so
as i said i don't really understand it's
really weird because if you look on like
rotten tomatoes for example
um
critically
it's weird because this got like largely
negative reviews i think it only has 13
critically but roger ebert actually
really liked it he thought it was like
the and he likes the first one too but
he was like i think this might be better
than the first i think i like this one
better than the than the uh than the
first one
which you know that's fair enough it's
it's along the lines of the first yeah
like i said and i didn't really get
um you know when we were watching it i
was like i don't really get why people
don't i like this movie it's like yeah i
thought it was like pretty fun i thought
like the mythology was cool i thought
like all the special effects look good
there was like it wasn't like i said it
wasn't quite as fun or as funny as the
other ones
but i think it made up for it like in
really cool uh you know visuals there
was some funny [ __ ] in it like the part
where uh where batiats is ass catches on
fire yeah he goes slapped by it
like that was pretty funny uh the
[ __ ] crazy ass um
uh
airplane pilot that was like driving
them up is like flying him up in the
plane that dude was funny but you know
i you know and i i get that they
couldn't get rachel weiss and that was
kind of like disappointing but i'm not
gonna like [ __ ] on maria bello for that
because she was fine in it she just
didn't seem like the same character
but what are you gonna do that's a
completely different one i wasn't really
worried about it i was just watching the
movie you know what i mean yeah and
enjoying it uh i don't think the content
i don't think
i don't think the continuity was
affected if you asked me but then again
you know what i mean i'm [ __ ] 50
something years old watching these
things they're they're for teenagers and
[ __ ] young
kids i think that's for the youtube
that's fine i yelled people and so
they might get butt hurt over the fact
that the [ __ ] that the cast chain that
she got replaced but she couldn't make
the movie you know what i mean so i mean
i wasn't but i was just
i just kind of wish i kind of wish if
they couldn't get her back
then they would have had i don't know
that they would have had her die and
then like it's that many years later and
he remarried and this is a different
woman that's kind of why because it's a
little weird that it seems like it's
supposed to be the same woman even
though it's clearly not the same woman
and she doesn't like even act the same
so that's why i kind of wish that they
would have just like written as like oh
she died during a dig in [ __ ] somewhere
and then like it's because it was years
later so it's like he conceivably could
have remarried so maybe they should have
wanted that same character i know but
you know they couldn't get the same
woman so
uh you plan on watching the scorpion
king
we might get around to it um not high on
the priority it's not yeah i mean
we're kind of like sends it to us people
will watch it oh yes he's he's fishing
yeah he's fishing for free movies
i don't know is it on it might be on
hulu because i was looking earlier today
and i think all the mummy movies are on
hulu but i'm not i'm not really sure
so i don't know but like i said i don't
really get the hate for this movie um
it's weird because
oh what i was going to say was rotten
tomatoes like 13 critical and i think it
was 30
audience but then if you go to google
users it's 80 positive
so
maybe now that like time has passed and
people are seeing it
just as its own movie and are not
expecting it to be one way or the other
or you know aren't like disappointed
because you know oh this is the new
thing and
as you would have been back in 2008 oh
i've been wanting to see a new mummy
movie and then it's not quite what you
wanted um so now that it's kind of like
removed from that context maybe people
can just like enjoy it as a movie and
not worry about
the continuity or anything like that so
maybe that's what it is maybe younger
people are seeing it now and just be
like what it's a you know it's just a
cool movie like i said i really did like
the whole uh you know the whole
aspect of the terracotta soldiers and
stuff and honestly i kind of would have
liked to seen what they would have done
with like an aztec kind of [ __ ] but they
just never got around to making it this
cause you know universal decided they
were gonna do the dark universe thing
and we all see how that went over
just like a wet fart
um you know what i mean
now
please somebody tell me the mum the the
tom cruise mummy
from 2017. that masterpiece
that masterpiece because he's he's
trying to like stir some trouble up
um
[Laughter]
you would maybe two or three other
people i don't know no i'm just kidding
i'm sure there's more than that i just
did i didn't hate it i just didn't think
it was that good but um
what now was it supposed to be a sequel
to these or was it a reboot you know
i've heard because i heard some people
talking about they said no that was
supposed to be a sequel because some of
the [ __ ] that was in the brendan fraser
mummy movies like the book of the dead
and stuff like looked the same in that
and i was like i don't remember like i i
don't remember like hardly a single
thing that happened in the tom cruise
one so it's like i didn't remember if
that book was in there so is it was it
supposed to be a sequel
i don't know i don't know
i mean i i
these studios are run by dorks they're
just and they're systems dudes and real
nerdy and
they saw what happened with the mcu and
they said oh well we can just keep we
can do that yeah it'll just unfold and
this and that like a system is like a
system
and they got
all audience members that like systems
but i think mcu burned that out because
everybody else tries to do it it fails
well the thing too about marvel was that
they already had tons of [ __ ] that they
could draw on from years and years of
comic books they already had all these
interconnected stories and yeah this
superhero meets that super so they
already had like a framework for that
whereas the the universal monster movies
even though yeah they made them all at
the same and it was the same studio and
stuff but those monsters were all like
separate
you know they were separate pocket
universes so much harder to like cross
them so to try to do what [ __ ] and
the thing is is like look man the mcu
has played out that model people are
sick of that
it's just not going to work
the proof is is just what i told you i
mean
aquaman and all that [ __ ]
they had some okay hits but they never
really could get that to become the mcu
and then
out of nowhere they
comes the joker which has nothing to
it's a pocket universe [ __ ] movie it
[ __ ] makes a billion dollars
and uh they didn't cost it it didn't
cost anything to make it and then the
people in their own studios tried to
[ __ ] oh don't go see it just in cells
are going to go see it and just they
were bad talking that movie in on in the
[ __ ] online press trying not trying
to get people not to see it and
[ __ ] blew up it's because they
didn't like what the movie said all
right
uh you read go see the movie and read in
between the lines you'll see exactly why
they didn't want you to see in that
movie
and then
then they come out with the batman and
now they're disappointed in the batman
it did because it didn't make a billion
dollars it made eight hundred thousand i
think
which would still be pretty good but now
they're thinking about well we might
have to scrap this because it didn't
make a billion these dudes are [ __ ]
man well that's the thing you will you
get one to a thing where it's like you
they expect every movie to make a
billion dollars so then it's like it
makes 800 million it's like oh that's
not good enough right even though 800
million is pretty good for like the 40
bajillionth batman movie they made you
think people be sick of batman by now
but no you could probably fix african
nick country with with 800 800 that's
what i mean and so these dudes are
[ __ ] that's what i mean like [ __ ]
schlubs like me that are like live from
paycheck to paycheck and it's just kind
of like oh 800 billion dollars is that
or 800 million dollars is suddenly not
good enough for you yes not not enough
for like the 40 billionth batman movie
that people are absolutely still going
to see
and and this is this is the type of
it's corruption too it's it's all trying
to spread money around it between
friends and probably a bunch of [ __ ]
laundering and [ __ ] going on because if
you wanted to make another billion
dollars
should have just made another [ __ ]
joker movie where what does the joker do
after that you'd made a lot of money on
that
although the sequel the sequel never
makes as much as the people still would
have gone to see it they would have yeah
and you would have the same [ __ ] dude
[ __ ] what's his name joaquin phoenix
playing it and it's still written like a
damn masterpiece you wouldn't even need
batman in it just he just put you know
the joker does this big [ __ ] caper
but you see
you know that movie came out and then
[ __ ] just months later that happened
in real life almost
[ __ ] city started burning and [ __ ]
and it was basically an antifa riot and
that's really what the joker was he just
some [ __ ] cry baby
you know kind of dude who [ __ ]
started a damn antifa [ __ ] riot you
know
and and
that's why i didn't want people to go
see it if you ask me
they didn't like that idea they didn't
think that that [ __ ]
portrayed their movement well
but it was realistic that's what it
really looked like that's what it really
looks like when you rise up against the
man it really just city's bird you steal
televisions and [ __ ]
you know destroys the city
then you got some crybaby walking around
murderer
but it was a great movie [ __ ] the
[ __ ] joker was a damn masterpiece and
that that's
that's the kind of movies that came out
of old hollywood that's the way oh well
actually no
i'm talking those are kind of like the
indie films that came out of the old
hollywood type stuff you know it was
like
scorsese film or something it was good
real good and they just could have done
that again they could have done batman
in that style
and made a lot of money
but you see then you don't have the
merchandising and you don't have sell
the toy contracts and if and it's rated
r so the kids can't see it and [ __ ]
if you want to make a billion dollars
that's the movie's got to be rated r
zach says i think the second uncharted
game handled the whole shangri-la mythos
a lot better i haven't played that game
so i don't really know
um
but like i said
i i just respect that they [ __ ]
decided they were going to do something
completely different with the thing as
much as i loved all love all the egypt
[ __ ] because i love that but you can't
just keep going back to that well you
know what i mean people would get bored
with it so you know i think they did a
good job [ __ ] it wasn't the same
director it was uh
he produced it the guy stephen summers
uh the director on the first two mummy
movies he produced it but this was
actually directed by what's that dude's
name that was [ __ ]
that rapey dude oh uh rob cohen yeah the
one that did um triple x and fast the
first fast and the furious that guy he
was the one that directed uh this one
and i think he was gonna do
the fourth one as well but then they
decided not to do it
so
all right so are we done talking about
the mummy movie yep
all right so it's tuesday which means
tomorrow is going to be our big main
show we're going to make somebody and
we're going to be talking about
road rage all right on tomorrow
evening's show that'll all i have like
four different uh incidents because a
couple people have like recommended ones
to me that i'm going to talk about so
we're going to talk about sort of like
the four most notorious like road rage
incidents so that should be
uh it's kind of a fun show probably
probably depressing too as well but you
know what i mean uh so yeah thanks for
hanging out with us today talking about
the mummy trilogy and we will see you
guys again tomorrow evening bye